après un an de travaux la cuisine
centrale d'orléans ouvre une légumerie
local 168 milles euros ont été
nécessaires pour agrandir les locaux
capables aujourd'hui d'accueillir deux
mille repas par jour contre 1200
auparavant le but est d'apporter un
soutien à l'agriculture locale
mais pas seulement écouter aux côtés des
circuits de proximité c'était en fait
des produits locaux l'objectif c'est
également les circuits courts circuits
courts c'est pas forcément que des
produits de proximité sont des produits
qui sont qui vont directement du
producteur à l'assiette
c'est donc du coup la livraison de la
légumerie aujourd'hui qui va permettre
de transformer directement les produits
qui vont arriver des agriculteurs